[Musique]
vous avez parlé à votre père
récemment
pourquoi
appelez-nous d'ù est-ce que tu sors toi
Oklahoma
je suis jamais sortie de cette
ville tu faisais quoi avec Madame
muscle on a surtout des étrangers un peu
débil ça va les
gar ça c'estck
ch du travail est prête à tout faire
que vra que tu
F casque un coup de point
non appelle-moi quand ce sera
fait c'est quoi cet
endroit je peux pas
comprendre remonte dans la
[Musique]
voiture ils ont trouvé le corps en
direct en a plein les
bras tu vas le
regretter
il va falloir qu'on se
venge je vais le raconter tout ce que tu
as fait F ouvre est-ce que tu
menaces
[Musique]
vraent
tombe jamais amoureuse
[Musique]
OK